The CW's Riverdale promised a sexy, updated
take on the classic Archie comics series,
and thus far, the show has delivered.
Taking the comics' central group of teens
and placing them smack dab in the middle of
a burgeoning murder mystery, Riverdale has
the intrigue, sass, and fun of a bona fide
hit.
It also has taken a lot of liberties with
how the characters appear and act compared
to the comics.
Here's a peek at how the cast of Riverdale
should really look.
Archie Andrews
Archie is one of the most famous redheads
in pop culture, so of course actor K.J.
Apa would have to dye his naturally brown
hair red for the part.
However, despite the fact that Apa spent ten
hours in a salon struggling to get the "right
shade of orange," it's nowhere near as light
as Archie's hair from the comics.
Apa is also missing the character's signature
freckles.
They did get the eyebrows pretty much perfect,
though.
Of course, the show also had to CW-ify Archie
a little.
"Oh..
My God!"
"What?"
"Game changer!
Archie got hot!
He's got abs now!"
The comic version of Archie wasn't exactly
running around Riverdale showing off his six-pack,
and, while he rocks some pretty great cheekbones
in the newer comics, classic Archie was much
more of a baby face.
Still, the show's fans don't seem to be complaining.
Jughead Jones
Cole Sprouse made a huge transformation from
Suite Life child star to the angsty version
of Jughead Jones shown on Riverdale.
The actor had to dye his naturally blonde
hair dark brown for the part, although he
keeps it slightly longer than Jughead does
in the comics.
Still, Sprouse did a great job of adopting
Jughead's signature squint and beanie.
The only real thing keeping him from being
a dead ringer from the character is the nose.
In the original Archie comics, Jughead has
a Pinnochio-style nose, which Sprouse — thankfully
— lacks.
Fred Andrews
Archie's dad Fred in the comics is overweight
and nearly bald.
But The CW decided to give Poppa Andrews a
little bit of an upgrade, casting former Beverly
Hills, 90210 heartthrob Luke Perry in the
part.
Perry's Fred is pretty buff, with a bit of
a beard and a messy hairstyle to match.
He's also definitely not sporting the tiny
mustache Fred has in the comics.
Which is fine.
While we don't mind Perry's facial hair at
all, a bald Perry with a beer belly isn't
really what anybody wants.
We feel old enough as it is just seeing him
be a dad.
Cheryl Blossom
Cheryl Blossom gets a much bigger role in
Riverdale than in the Archie comics, where
she mostly just serves as a supporting character
and further romantic rival for Archie.
On the show, Cheryl and her brother Jason
are at the center of the show's murder mystery,
and what Cheryl knows could end up being the
key to solving the crime.
Like her comic book counterpart, Madelaine
Petsch is a redhead, although her hair is
a bit darker than the character's bright locks.
Petsch also has brown eyes, while Cheryl is
usually shown with green eyes in the comics.
But we're not criticizing.
After all, we've all seen what happens when
you end up on Cheryl's bad side.
Kevin Keller
Kevin is fairly new to the comics, introduced
in 2010 as the series' first openly gay character.
In the comics, Kevin is blonde, as opposed
to actor Casey Cott, who has dark brown hair.
Cott also has green eyes, while in the comic,
they're blue.
So… he pretty much looks nothing like the
comics version of Kevin.
But who cares?
He just better keep making those snarky comments
directly to the audience.
"Should we maybe re-binge Making a Murderer
on Netflix tonight?"
Betty Cooper
Riverdale's resident brilliant blonde is played
on the show by Lili Reinhart, who's shown
she already has the character's sweet persona
down pat.
However, while the actress does sport Betty's
signature blonde ponytail, her hair is a little
darker than the comics' yellow.
She also doesn't have the bangs that Betty
is usually depicted with.
Other than that, though, Reinhart is pretty
much a dead ringer for her classic character.
Veronica Lodge
Actress Camila Mendes said she wasn't planning
on auditioning for the part of Veronica until
she found out producers were making the character
Latina, a departure from her Caucasian background
in the comics.
Mendes, who is Brazilian, said she liked that
the character "wasn't a stereotype" of Latinas,
which ended up attracting her to the role.
Aside from Riverdale's change in Veronica's
background, Mendes is pretty much identical
to her comic book counterpart, with the same
striking beauty and dark hair.
Reggie Mantle
Archie's comic book rival Reggie is played
by former Disney Channel actor Ross Butler
on Riverdale, changing the character's Caucasian
background to Eurasian.
However, Butler definitely has the slicked-back
dark hair, cocky attitude, and good looks
to bring Riverdale's resident bad boy Reggie
to life.
Now if only he'd get more screen time...
Josie McCoy
Riverdale made the decision to make the entirety
of the Josie and the Pussycats lineup African-American
— unlike the comics, which featured two
white characters.
Ashleigh Murray leads the band as Josie McCoy,
embodying the character's signature sass,
spunk, and musical talent pretty much perfectly.
In the comics and cartoons, Josie is a yet
another redhead, only she also likes to wear
cat ears and a cat suit while rocking out
— naturally.
Riverdale moved away from the character's
outlandish style into more toned-down, fashion-forward
outfits, which reflects the character's transition
from sweet girl to ambitious rocker.
Which, y'know, rocks.
Bah boom, sssss!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!